I found a way to start day trading with
just $4. And this is exactly what I do
if I had to start over from scratch. And
the best asset to do with this with is
called futures. I've built a strategy
where I only trade for 60 minutes every
morning. [music] And if you have a
full-time job, it's perfect for you. I
struggled for years to become
consistently profitable. But once I
focused on this one simple strategy,
everything changed for me. [music] And
not just for me, but for other traders
I've taught this as well. Years ago, I
was risking about $50 per trade making
$100 per trade. And now, years later, I
am risking around $1,500 per trade, and
I can make over $5,000
on a single trade in just that 60-minute
window. So, after years of watching the
S&P 500 index, I noticed something. In
the first 60 minutes every single
morning, the market always has
volatility. It pushes hard in one
direction, and then often reverses the
other way. And so, what I did is I
[music] built a simple five-step entry
checklist to take advantage of that move
that happened. This completely changed
my trading for the better because if the
setup isn't there, I don't trade. I just
move on with my day and try again
tomorrow. Now, one shift alone stopped
me from consistently losing money
trading. So, every morning, I mark key
reversal zones on the 15-minute chart.
Then I drop down and wait for price to
come into that area and show signs of a
reversal. The confirmation I like to use
is looking for patterns like a head and
shoulders, a double bottom, and I don't
like to use other indicators. [music] I
just use price action, trend lines, and
support and [music] resistance levels.
Over time, I realized I actually don't
need anything else. More indicators
actually made things more complicated
for me, and simpler actually made me
more profitable when it comes to
trading. Now, once I'm in a trade, I
manage my risk, trail my stop, and as
price moves in my favor, I exit when the
momentum starts to slow down. Now,
here's what makes this really powerful.
You can start practicing this with
almost no money. The platform I've used
for over 5 years now is called
NinjaTrader. You can start practicing
trading using real-time market data for
around $4 a month, which is cheaper than
most platforms. And I'll leave a link
for this in the description if you want
to check it out. And when you're ready
to switch to real money, futures allows
you to start as little as 20 to $50 of
risk per trade. That's why I think
futures are one of the best ways as a
beginner to get started. You can start
[music] really small and scale up over
time using the exact same strategy. I
also don't recommend starting with prop
firms as a beginner. Early on, you're
going to make mistakes. That's a part of
the process. But with a prop firm, those
mistakes [music] get more and more
expensive. You're essentially paying
over and over to demo trade. It's
statistically proven that it's extremely
hard for a beginner and just anyone in
general to pass a prop firm challenge
and actually get access to a real
account. It's much better to practice
first then slowly transition into
risking small amounts of real money,
like $20 per trade, [music] and build
that up over time. That way, you can
build the mental side of trading
gradually. With prop firms, it's often
zero to 100. You're demo trading, and
then all of a sudden you're managing a
$100,000 account, and you're about to
make $8,000 on a trade if it's
profitable. And most beginners can't
make that switch. It becomes way too
intense too fast. That's why I believe a
slow, scalable approach is the better
path. So, let's go over the basics of
futures so you can have a clear
understanding of how [music] they work.
Futures work differently than stocks in
many ways, but once you understand them,
it's very, very simple, just like
trading a normal stock. That's what drew
them to me in [music] the beginning. If
you buy it and it goes up, you make
money. And if it goes down, you lose
money. The first big [music] difference
is when you buy one share of, let's say,
Apple, you can hold that share as long
as you want. You own a piece of
>> [music]
>> that company and it never expires unless
the company goes bankrupt. With futures,
you aren't actually [music] buying a
share of something. You're buying a
contract agreement, and the value of
that is based on the market [music] it's
connected with. So, for example, if you
buy one futures contract of the oils
market, the contract value goes up if
the price [music] in oil increases, and
the contract's value goes down if it
decreases. [music] The exact same way
your share price of Apple would go up
and down. So, when it comes to trading,
there's really no difference there, but
the only thing is the futures contracts
expire, unlike shares. [music] The
length of a futures contract depends on
the market you're trading, but
generally, it's one or three months.
This is the one reason why futures are
better for short-term trading. It's not
something you hold long-term. For you
and me, they're really day trading
assets. [music] Now, technically, when
you buy an oil futures contract, you're
buying the ability to buy [music] 1,000
barrels of oil at a certain price. But
in reality, you're never doing [music]
that. You are just using this contract
as leverage because buying this contract
costs a fraction of the price of [music]
purchasing a thousand barrels of oil,
but you get the value increase or
decrease of those a thousand barrels of
oil. It's the exact same thing as buying
a house with a loan. [music]
You get the increase or decrease in the
value of the house, but you only have to
put up a fraction of the cost as a down
payment. In the trading world, that down
payment on the house is called a margin
requirement. Just think of it like
collateral. You have to put up to get
one [music] futures contract of oil. For
example, buying one contract of the S&P
500 futures can take $500 worth of
margin.
>> [music]
>> Your account will have $500 taken away,
but then when you sell the contract
back, you get that $500 worth of margin
back. Now, this isn't taken into account
the profit [music]
or loss you made on that trade. So, when
you see the price of the S&P 500 futures
trading at something like
>> [music]
>> 7,000, it doesn't cost you $7,000 to buy
one contract. It's based on the margin
requirement at the time. Now, the margin
requirement differs [music] from market
to market and brokerage to brokerage and
what time of day it is. So, let's break
that down cuz that's kind of confusing.
First off, you have what is called
intraday and overnight margin.
>> [music]
>> For example, US stocks are only open
during the New York trading session,
which is 9:30 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
to 4:00 p.m. [music] Eastern Standard
Time. This is the only time you can
trade stocks. Futures on the other hand
are almost open 24 hours a day, 6 days a
week. They technically close for a short
amount of time after the New York
session closes and also over the
weekend. But, that's how the intraday
and overnight margin [music] difference
is made. So, the requirements for
intraday margin are pretty much 22 hours
>> [music]
>> out of the day. Even though it's called
intraday, it's technically while the
market
>> [music]
>> is trading during the day and trading
during the night, you have that lower
intraday margin requirement. And then
the overnight margin requirement, or
another way to say it is maintenance
[music] margin, is just for when the
market is actually closed. The whole
reason for this is the risk [music] is
higher because the market closes and it
can have news happen while it's closed
and then there can be a huge jump or
change in price, which adds risk to a
trade. And so that's why
>> [music]
>> the brokerages require higher margin.
And so the overnight margin requirements
are only from that 4:45 p.m. Eastern
[music] Standard Time to 6:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time. The market's
closed for about an hour and so you have
to have the higher margin requirement
just for that hour every day. And so
it's closed for the weekend and so on
Friday at 4:45 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time, that lower margin requirement will
shoot back up to the overnight margin
requirement and then it'll be closed all
the way until Sunday at 6:00 [music]
p.m. Eastern Standard Time. This also
works for holidays where it's closed and
that'll also have a higher margin
>> [music]
>> requirement. Now these margin
requirements can change based on
brokerage. [music] For the intraday
margin, some brokerages don't have a
lower margin requirement, which can be
[music] around $7,000
for one ES futures contract. [music]
Others have low margin requirements and
this is where the power of futures
really comes into play. It's platforms
like NinjaTrader that I use only require
$500 worth of margin for one contract of
the S&P 500 futures, which is tiny for
how much leverage it actually gives you.
But for almost all platforms, the
overnight margin, which [music] is
initial margin or maintenance margin, is
never reduced. It's always at that
massive size of [music]
$7,000 and you can always find these
numbers looking at your specific [music]
brokerage. But these can also change if
the volatility of the market goes crazy.
[music] Usually, when the market is
crashing, like during COVID or any of
these last big spikes lower that the
market has had since then, that even the
intraday margin, like a NinjaTrader, can
go from 500 to [music] $1,500. And
that's because the volatility in the
market is so big that they essentially
the brokerages require more collateral
for you to [music] take a trade because
the risk is higher. You'll often get an
alert from your brokerage to know when
this is happening. [music] Now, another
minor difference between future
contracts is you have ones like oil
where you're actually gaining control
over a physical object. If you held your
contract expiration and exercised it, it
would settle with barrels of oil. You
would technically get an email saying,
"This is where you go pick up your 1,000
barrels of oil." Other ones like the
indexes, like the S&P 500, they aren't
based on a physical object, and it's
just settled [music] in cash. Now, don't
worry, 1,000 barrels isn't really going
to show up at your house or be delivered
to you. If you're day trading or even
holding them over a couple of days, this
will likely never happen. And even if it
does, you can always just sell those
back without actually doing anything
[music] with them. And when it gets to
the end of a contract, because they
expire, you start trading the new
contract. This is called rollover. On
NinjaTrader and other platforms, you
generally don't have to worry about this
as the system will automatically update
it [music] or send you a pop-up
notification when it's time to do that.
And all this means in NinjaTrader is you
are changing the ticker symbol, which is
technically has the date of the contract
in it, to the next one. So, for the S&P
500 futures, which expires every 3
months, it's always the same month and
third expiration of that month. Pretty
much you get one that expires [music]
every quarter. So, you have one that
expires 03, 06, 09, [music]
and 12. Those are the months of the
year. And then, you put the year at the
end of it. So, [music]
if you're looking at the expiration of
June 26, the ticker would look like ES
626. [music]
And that's just saying the month of
expiration. Now, I've always found that
changing over the Monday of expiration
week is the way to go. That's when most
people switch over, so the volume
changes to the new contract. Also, this
way you never have to worry about
dealing with 1,000 barrels of oil
showing up at your house. And at least
for NinjaTrader, it will automatically
do [music] this generally when it's time
on that Monday. It's not really
something you have to worry about, but
you want to be aware of it. Now, that
$500 worth of margin for one S&P 500
futures contract is still a massive
amount for a small account if you're
wanting to start trading a small amount
and increase your size. So, what you can
do [music]
is you can trade something called the
micro futures contracts. All the large
futures contracts like the S&P 500, the
Nasdaq, oil, gold, they all have one and
they're essentially a tenth of [music]
the size. So, for the S&P 500 futures,
it costs $50 worth of margin to get
control over one contract, but the value
and price movement you gain is also a
tenth of the size. It's a super simple
way to start small and grow your
account. This is how you can risk as
little as $20 per trade. I did the exact
same thing with my account when I
started. I started trading the S&P 500
futures micro contracts, and I slowly
traded more and more. I traded one
contract, then I took two, then I had
three contracts per trade, and over
time, I eventually switched [music]
to the mini contracts. It's a little
confusing with having micro and mini,
but the mini are the normal size that I
currently [music] trade and what you'll
eventually scale up to. Now, the other
massive difference between shares
[music]
and futures is how the movement in price
relates to the dollar change of your
trade. [music] For shares, it's really
simple. They're based on the dollar
movement. And [music] so, if it goes up
one penny, you make one penny on each
share you own. Its value is based on the
dollar. Now, with futures, it's
completely different. First, the price
[music]
movement isn't based on money. So, if
you're looking at, let's say, the ES
futures, one ES contract goes from 7,000
to 7,001, your contract value doesn't go
up $1. It actually goes up $50. And this
incremental movement of one is actually
called one point. Now, going back to
shares, the smallest amount they can
move is one penny, right? Apple can move
from $100 to $100 and one penny. But
this isn't the smallest amount of
movement that futures contracts have.
The ES futures, the smallest amount they
move is
>> [music]
>> 0.25,
which is called one tick. One tick
[music] is essentially the smallest
amount of movement in any futures
contract, and that tick size will
essentially change. But for the ES, it's
1/4 of the point, so it's valued [music]
at each tick movement is $12.50.
And these change from market to market.
And so, for the ES futures, the smallest
tick is 0.25 and it's $50 a point. But
for oil, the smallest tick movement is
0.01, [music]
and it's valued at $10 a tick. So, one
point of movement in oil is $1,000.
[music]
But if you look at the two markets, the
amount they move is drastically
different. Oil moves on a much smaller
scale, so the sizing makes sense. It's
generally only valued between 60 [music]
and $80 when the ES futures are trading
at around 7,000 [music]
right now. Now, one thing to be aware of
trading futures is you are
over-leveraging
yourself. Only putting [music] up $500
worth of margin isn't your max loss on a
trade. Technically, [music] you own one
contract of the ES futures, and if the
market suddenly crashes, you could lose
more money than your account. Now, I've
never had this happen, and it almost
never does happen. There's a few ways to
protect yourself from this happening.
One is always have a stop loss in place
no matter what, [music] and never move
it further away, increasing your
potential risk [music] once you're in a
trade. Because if the market opens and
goes against you really quick, this will
get you out of the trade as fast as
possible, not allowing you to take an
overly large loss. And really, the only
way to have this happen of stories that
I've seen where people do lose more
money than their account is they hold
something into the market close. So, for
example, let's look at a chart right
here. This is the S&P 500 futures on a
15-minute, and if you [music]
held a contract into the market close
right here with a stop loss down here,
well, technically, when the market
opened again, it opened all the way down
here, which was would completely blow
through your stop loss. That's how you
lose a larger amount of money. And so,
[music] because of that, just don't hold
through the market close. There's really
no reason to do that. Lastly, the only
fees that come with trading futures are
pretty much commissions and some fees
[music] added on by the processing
companies that make these trades happen.
These will generally differ slightly
between futures contracts and also
platforms you're trading, [music]
but the brokerages are so competitive
now, it's pretty much the same across
the board.
>> [music]
>> And as well, even though we talked about
margin, there's no interest rates or
[music]
fees with taking out margin, at least
for trading futures.
>> [music]
>> So, I know this is an insane amount of
information and can get really confusing
when you first hear it. I want to go
into a chart now and show you the
practicality [music] of actually doing
this and show you that it's really not
that complicated. It seems like a lot
initially, but when it actually [music]
comes to trading, it's pretty simple. I
want to quickly show you a trade I took
from a little while ago to just kind of
show you the smaller size version of
what we're talking about and the
practicality of things. And so,
basically is, you know, I don't want to
get into my strategy too much. I just
want to kind of look at the practicality
of how they work. And so, you know, I
see that the market's coming down to an
area that I would like to look for a
reversal trade off of. And so, all I do
is on NinjaTrader, you're able to click
on the chart to put in a buy stop order.
And so, I put in a buy stop order right
here for three contracts and I'm saying,
"Okay, if the price hits here again, I
want to enter in on a trade." And so, it
enters in. You can see this is the
price, the dollar movement going up and
down. And so, you can move your stop
loss right here just on the screen. And
so, I had it essentially below this kind
of bottom we put in. And then from
there, you can kind of see the dollar
value go up and down. And it's a smaller
amount of money than what I normally
trade right now, but this is the
practicality and the scaling part of it,
which is really, really good. Now, this
is still pretty decent size. You can go
way smaller than this if you're trading
the S&P 500 and trading, you know, one
contract versus three. And so, just to
kind of zoom this through is kind of
once it it kind of gets going here is I
move my stop loss up to something like
break even here. And then I start to,
you can see I I break up my trade into
multiple orders. And I scaled out here
once it kind of got up to a nice amount
of profit that I like. You know, you can
see here it goes from three contracts to
one contract cuz I closed out for a
profit on a couple of those. And then
from there, so this is how you could see
just what one contract would be is you
could you could trade these swings and
you know get $100 or $200 per contract
on a swing like this. And this is how I
don't scalp when it comes to futures.
Some people look for really small moves.
I still look for swing trades on a daily
chart. For me, it's a little bit easier
to become profitable doing that. And to
me, my strategy has worked really well
for that. [music] And you can see over
here on the left side, the Nasdaq also
has one tick, the smallest size it moves
is 0.25.
It's happening pretty quick. The Nasdaq
you can see is valued much higher than
the S&P 500 futures. The Nasdaq at this
time is around 19,000 and I think during
this time the ES was valued at around
5,000. Now in current market, it's much
higher, but it's the same thing. And
[music] you can see here and it moves up
and down based on 0.25 increments. You
know, it can jump a little bit because
the price is moving so quickly. And so
that's how it works out. And you know,
usually you can you can I find it just
super practical to trade. Now to get
started practicing everything, make sure
you get NinjaTrader. I'll leave a link
for it in the description below. Now if
you want a video that goes into my
strategy more, check out this video
right here. It goes into my five-step
entry checklist [music]
in detail. And make sure you come watch
me live stream my trading on YouTube
every morning at 9:15 Eastern Standard
Time.